[Música]
Hola hoy en Sainz clic las ondas
electromagnéticas
imaginemos una partícula con carga
eléctrica
debido a su carga la partícula genera un
campo eléctrico a su alrededor
este campo eléctrico no varía con el
tiempo ya que la carga permanece inmóvil
ahora imaginemos que aceleramos esta
carga de manera que se ponga en
movimiento al producirse la aceleración
la partícula adquirirá una velocidad
según la relatividad especial esta
velocidad causa la aparición de un campo
magnético a su alrededor el campo
eléctrico y el campo magnético son dos
caras de un mismo objeto el campo
electromagnético y por ello interactúan
entre sí en particular el campo
magnético que ha aparecido perturba el
campo eléctrico esta perturbación del
campo eléctrico perturbara a su vez el
campo magnético poco a poco los campos
eléctrico y magnéticos se influyen
mutuamente y varían uno tras otro
perturbación tras perturbación
el movimiento infligido a la partícula
repercutirá en todo el espacio poco a
poco propagándose la velocidad de la luz
a través de los campos eléctricos y
magnético a este fenómeno se le llama
onda electromagnética
dependiendo de la aceleración de la
partícula que la genera una onda
electromagnética tendrá una energía
mayor o menor así las ondas pueden
clasificarse en varias categorías de
energía según la frecuencia a la que
oscilan entre ellas se encuentra luz
visible con los diferentes colores del
Arcoiris pero no es la única el
infrarrojo el ultravioleta las
microondas los rayos x las ondas de
radio y los rayos Gamma son ondas que no
podemos ver con nuestros ojos pero
también son ondas electromagnéticas la
gran mayoría de esta radiaciones son
invisibles para nosotros pero con
nuestras tecnologías actuales es posible
construir cámaras e instrumentos de
medición especiales para detectarlas o
emitirlas es lo que se utiliza en los
hornos microondas en las
telecomunicaciones y en otras
transmisiones a distancia pero también
en la astronomía y en los telescopios
espaciales los astrónomos observan el
universo con diferentes tipos de ondas
ya listo tiene una imagen mucho más
extensa que la que se obtiene solo con
la luz visible
las ondas electromagnéticas están
presentes en todas partes cada vez que
las partículas cargadas se mueven
generan estas ondas que se propagan en
el universo
en especial cualquier objeto que tenga
una temperatura emite dicha radiación
para entenderlo es necesario hacer la
observación a escala microscópica Aquí
la temperatura de un objeto corresponde
a la agitación de sus átomos cada átomo
Está compuesto por dos partes un núcleo
con cargas positivas y una nube de
electrones negativa al agitarse los
átomos hacen vibrar sus nubes de
electrones se comportan como si
estuviesen enlazadas al núcleo por una
cinta elástica al vibrar todas estas
cargas eléctricas están en constante
aceleración y cambio de dirección de
esta forma los átomos emitirán ondas
electromagnéticas que serán tanto más
energéticas cuanto mayor sea la
temperatura del objeto
el cuerpo humano por ejemplo con una
temperatura de unos 37 grados
centígrados emite permanentemente
radiación infrarroja
estas ondas no son visibles para
nuestros ojos pero podemos detectarlas
con cámaras térmicas
una característica muy interesante de
las ondas electromagnéticas es la
llamada polarización
según hemos visto antes las nubes
electrónicas de los átomos se comportan
algo así como si estuviesen enlazados al
núcleo por una cinta elástica cuando los
átomos se agitan las nubes de electrones
vibran a todas las direcciones y las
ondas generadas tienen una estructura
más bien caótica este tipo de onda es no
polarizada
supongamos ahora que emitimos una onda
con estas características hacia una
partícula con carga a su paso la
partícula experimentará una fuerza
puesto que interactuará con los campos
que conforman la onda entonces empezará
a vibrar de la misma manera que la onda
Así es como el sol es capaz de calentar
la atmósfera de la tierra a millones de
kilómetros de distancia su calor se
transmite desde su superficie a nuestra
atmósfera a través de ondas
electromagnéticas que se propagan por el
vacío
sin embargo en algunas situaciones es
posible hacer que los átomos vibren de
forma más controlada podrán vibrar de
tres maneras posibles
imaginemos una canica colocada sobre una
mesa y conectada a un clavo mediante una
cinta elástica muy tensa imaginemos que
lanzamos la canica con diferentes
velocidades su trayectoria formará la
mayoría de las veces elipses y a veces
líneas rectas e incluso círculos
perfectos en los átomos las nubes
electrónicas son atraídas por los
núcleos del mismo modo que la canicas
atraída por el clavo así estos también
pueden vibrar de estas Tres formas
posibles y de este modo generar ondas
electromagnéticas con una forma
repetitiva ondas polarizadas con una
polarización rectilínea elíptica o
circular las antenas de radio Por
ejemplo provocan la oscilación de los
átomos a lo largo del eje de la antena
así generan ondas muy puras que oscilan
de forma regular con una polarización
rectilínea
en cuanto a la luz su polarización no es
directamente visible para nuestros ojos
nuestros ojos solo son sensibles a la
intensidad de la luz pero no a la
dirección de los campos sin embargo es
una propiedad muy importante que
determinará la forma en que la luz
interactúa con los objetos en particular
existen filtros que permiten absorber
ciertas polarizaciones en lugares de
otras se llaman polarizadores se
utilizan en particular para la
tecnología del cine en 3D donde se
pueden proyectar dos imágenes
simultáneamente con dos polarizaciones
diferentes y las gafas con lentes
polarizadoras pueden diseñarse de tal
forma que cada ojo reciba una imagen
diferente
por último como las ondas
electromagnéticas son ondas evolucionan
en el espacio según fenómenos muy
específicos en primer lugar como
cualquier otra onda se suman unas a
otras si superponemos dos crestas
obtendremos una cresta que es el doble
de grande mientras que si superponemos
una onda con su puesto Exacto las dos se
anularán Para que no haya ninguna onda
final
a este principio de su preposición de
ondas se le llama interferencia es la
base el fenómeno de la difracción que se
observa cuando una onda encuentra un
pequeño obstáculo o pasa por una rendija
muy fina
en segundo lugar como hemos visto
anteriormente al atravesar un medio
transparente compuesto por átomos una
onda electromagnética generará una
fuerza sobre las nubes electrónicas
estas vibraciones dentro de los átomos
emitirán a su vez ondas que comparten
aproximadamente las mismas
características que la onda inicial
Aunque lo iluminemos a partir de una
determinada dirección el medio producirá
una luz que se dispersa en todas las
direcciones es lo que se llama
dispersión la atmósfera terrestre es un
muy buen ejemplo del fenómeno de la
dispersión la atmósfera en sí no tiene
un verdadero color es un medio
transparente pero el sol está
continuamente emitiendo radiación
electromagnética hacia nuestro planeta
que se compone de todos los colores del
Arcoiris al pasar estas ondas los átomos
que componen el aire comenzarán a vibrar
y a dispersar la luz en todas las
direcciones pero Cuanto más energética
sea la onda más potente será el fenómeno
de la dispersión los tonos rojos son
relativamente débiles mientras que los
azules poseen más energía así pues son
las ondas de color azul las que harán
que los electrones duren más y se
dispercen razón por la cual el cielo nos
parece azul
por último cuando emitimos una onda
electromagnética contra un material por
ejemplo el agua una parte de la onda
seguirá su camino a través de este
mientras que la otra parte rebotará la
dirección contraria se dice que la onda
se refracta en una dirección y se
refleja en la otra primero examinamos el
fenómeno de la reflexión cuando la luz
incide sobre un material conductor como
el Metal de la superficie de un espejo
algunos de los electrones de la
superficie no están ligados a los átomos
Esto es lo que da al metal su capacidad
de conducir la electricidad Pero al
pasar la onda luminosa los campos
electromagnéticos que la componen
pondrán movimiento estos electrones
libres de este modo aparecerán
corrientes eléctricas en la superficie y
estas corrientes reproducirán
perfectamente la forma de la onda
incidente van así generar a su vez una
onda similar a la onda incidente pero
que se propaga a ambos lados de la
superficie en la parte superior esta
onda corresponde a la onda reflejada
cuando nos miramos en un espejo es esta
onda generada por las corrientes
eléctricas en el Metal la que veremos en
la parte inferior la onda generada por
las corrientes eléctricas es
perfectamente opuesta a la onda
incidente ambas interferirán de modo que
la onda inicial se anula
Por otra parte la fracción de la onda
que conseguirá atravesar la superficie
del agua parece propagarse en una
dirección ligeramente diferente y sobre
todo moverse más lentamente a esto se le
llama refracción la reflexión es un
fenómeno complejo Que de nuevo se debe a
las preposición de varias ondas cuando
la onda incidente pasa los átomos y sus
nubes electrónicas comienzan a vibrar en
el agua de modo que emiten nuevas ondas
que se suman a la onda original Pero
estas nuevas ondas están ligeramente
desplazadas de la onda incidente y esto
tendrá el efecto de ralentizar todo el
haz de luz
es importante entender que la velocidad
de la luz en sí no ha cambiado los
campos electromagnéticos reaccionan
siempre la misma velocidad y cada una de
las ondas generadas por los átomos se
mueve la velocidad de la luz pero el haz
de luz que tiene en cuenta la suma de
todas las ondas si se ralentiza debido a
la superposiciones así unas de luz
viajan más lentamente en ciertos
materiales que en el vacío y es posible
que las partículas superen la velocidad
de propagación de unas de luz en algunos
materiales
al igual que el estallido que se produce
cuando un avión supera la velocidad del
sonido este fenómeno provoca la
aparición de un Destello de luz lo que
se conoce como el efecto cherenkov y es
un método utilizado hoy en día por los
científicos para detectar neutrinos
[Música]